[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
historia este mes cuba celebra el
sexagésimo aniversario de uno de los
eventos más significativos y más
críticos en la historia de su revolución
la invasión de bahía cochinos una
invasión lanzada por cubanos exiliados
que buscaban derrocar a fidel castro y
que estaban armados entrenados y
alentados por la ciudad de los eeuu pero
cómo se llegó a este punto durante la
década de 1950 cuba estuvo gobernada por
el dictador y multimillonario fulgencio
batista
el coronel batista era un fiel aliado de
eeuu país que en la primera mitad del
siglo 20 había usufructuado la industria
de la caña y del turismo en la isla en
los años a cargo
batista aplastó cualquier signo de
protesta y rebelión de sus opositores
fueron los mismos años en que el abogado
fidel castro su hermano raúl los
comandantes camilo cienfuegos y huber
matos el médico argentino ernesto che
guevara y un grupo de militantes que lo
seguían
planearon una revolución este grupo de
guerrilleros se hacía llamar movimiento
26 de julio en honor a la fecha de la
toma fallida del cuartel moncada en 1953
el primer intento de fidel castro- de
alzarse con el poder y por el cual fue
enjuiciado y condenado a 15 años de
prisión
fidel castro- actuando como su propio
abogado alegó en su defensa la frase la
historia me absolverá 18 meses después
batista lo perdono a él ya sus
compañeros como gesto para congraciarse
con la sociedad cubana
en seguida castro y algunos de estos
hombres viajaron a méxico donde se
entrenaron militarmente castró consiguió
fondos para comprar un bote llamado
granma en el cual viajaron 82
revolucionarios con arsenal militar y
arribaron en 1956 al sur de cuba para
levantar un enclave en sierra maestra
durante dos años fidel y sus hombres
fueron ganando adeptos en todo el
territorio en parte como resultado a una
guerra de guerrillas pero
aun a una exitosa campaña de prensa
el 'new york times' calificó a fidel
castro como un robin hood en favor de
los cubanos sometidos por el régimen de
batista de manera que con el avance
acechante de los barbudos de la sierra
como les conocían eeuu le retiró el
apoyo a batista
el dictador sucumbió a la presión y
abandonó el país acompañado de sus
aliados y de 300 millones de dólares
rumbo hacia santo domingo república
dominicana- su partida le abrió las
puertas de la habana y de santiago de
cuba- a la revolución de fidel castro el
comandante y comenzó a fabricar un poder
desde el primero de enero de 1959 del
que no sospechaban en eeuu la revolución
había triunfado y traía consigo reformas
entre ellas la expropiación y expulsión
de grandes empresas estadounidenses así
como una reforma agrícola y social en
favor de los campesinos y los más pobres
el vice presidente richard nixon
advirtiendo una cuba comunista
planeo secretamente una intervención
militar en la isla como la única manera
para frenar que se convirtiera en un
satélite soviético entretanto en eeuu
john fitzgerald kennedy sorprendió a
richard nixon por un estrecho margen en
las elecciones de 1960 y quedó electo
presidente sin saber de los planes de
invasión a cuba cuando se enteró
kennedy se opuso a la invasión pero un
hecho fue clave el periodista tatsu del
'new york times' descubrió el plan de la
invasión y lo publicó pese al intento de
kennedy de que no se imprimiera de tal
suerte y habiendo el 'times' publicado
el artículo el 7 de abril de 1961
kennedy accedió a la invasión imponiendo
ciertas condiciones como reducir el
número de aviones de la fuerza aérea
para los bombardeos y cambiar el lugar
de desembarco de trinidad a bahía
cochinos el 15 de abril de 1961 un
bombardeo aéreo de los invasores atacó
bases aéreas cubanas y después más de
1300 cubanos exiliados
atracaron en bahía cochinos el ataque
fue considerado un éxito ya que
rápidamente controlaron las posiciones
de la bahía que incluían la playa girón
pero ante la noticia fidel castro-
movilizó tropas de forma masiva para
contener la invasión tras más de 60
horas de enfrentamientos el ejército de
fidel extinguió por completo el avance
contrarrevolucionario murieron 114
cubanos exiliados y más de 1200 fueron
arrestados aunque más de 4000 cubanos se
contaron entre muertos heridos y
desaparecidos
la batalla fue considerada una victoria
para cuba y una derrota en toda su línea
para los estadounidenses sin sus aliados
locales para el presidente kennedy la
derrota de los invasores en bahía
cochinos fue un desastre mediático un
fiasco político inconmensurable de
manera que ordenó planes para una nueva
invasión a cuba
en contrapartida fidel castro- se
aseguró de proteger a la isla de futuros
ataques estadounidenses bajo un estrecho
pacto de alianza con la unión soviética
microsoft de modo que 43 mil soldados
soviéticos se instalaron en cuba para
apoyar la legitimidad y la permanencia
de fidel en el poder con la victoria de
bahía cochinos fidel castro- materializó
uno de los mayores temores de los eeuu
en plena guerra fría que cuba se
convirtiera en un satélite de la unión
soviética armado con bombas nucleares
y a tan solo 144 kilómetros de distancia
el embargo económico de eeuu fue el
precio a pagar por cuba desde entonces y
hasta nuestros días un bloqueo que ha
significado en sus etapas más difíciles
un crudo desabastecimiento un profundo
aislamiento en una isla que ha
sobrevivido desafiante frente al inmenso
y poderoso eeuu así concluimos soy
andrés suárez jaramillo gracias por
compartir y comentar estas historias que
las encuentran en los programas de
france 24 punto com
[Música]